[संगीत]
हेलो गुड इवनिंग एवरीवन
वेलकम टुडे
और होने वाला है जितनी आपको रिटायरमेंट थी
जितना आपको सीखना था जितना आपका फंडामेंटल
स्टॉक होना था वो मैंने आप लोगों को
डिलीवर कर दिया है
सिक्योरिटी में आपको स्टार्टिंग में
रिटायरमेंट होता है एडरवाइज आपको सीखने के
लिए बहुत कुछ है बहुत कुछ है की अगर दिनेश
में अगर जितना दीप जाना चाहते हो जा सकते
हैं की इसके सर्टिफिकेट
है क्लाउड इंजीनियर है ये सारे सर्टिफिकेट
है तो एक बार मुझे यह सब बता दीजिए की
सबको मेरी आवाज ए रही है नहीं ए रही
बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज ए रही है या
नहीं ए रही
चलो फिर कम करते हैं
तो आपके लिए पर योर किड इनफॉरमेशन आज आपका
लास्ट
आपका डाउट सेशन होगा और उसमें अभी तक दे
13 तक आपने जो भी कुछ पढ़ा पढ़ा है अब जो
भी कुछ आपके डाउट्स हैं किसी भी कमांड्स
में अभी तक
सिलेबस में आप लोग मुझे पूछ सकते हैं मैं
आपको जवाब दूंगा
की आपको कुछ एडवाइस लेनी है वो भी ले सकते
हैं तो मुझे पोस्ट स्टार्ट करने से पहले
या एवं अगर कोई है सेशन खत्म होने के बाद
दो दिन बाद 5 दिन बाद अगर हमारे
रिकॉर्डिंग सेशन देखना
ज्यादा लोग होंगे इस हिसाब से हम फिर
बेस्ट फाइटिंग के बड़े में आप लोगों के
लिए सोचेंगे
अभी डिपेंड करता है की आप लोग कितना
सपोर्ट करते हो
इससे भी बेहतर तरीके से इससे भी बेस्ट
प्रोजेक्ट बेस पढ़ाऊंगा अगर पढ़ाऊंगा तो
बट मुझे उसके लिए आप लोगों को सपोर्ट
चाहिए मुझे जस्ट यह नहीं है की मुझे ओनली
किसी भी एक किसी भी प्रीवियस दे के अभी
मैंने जो लास्ट डेट 13 की बात करता हूं तो
डेट में मैंने क्या किया है की क्लास
देखिए 13 में सब अभी तक 200 लाइक यू भी
नहीं होंगे मुझे ऐसा नहीं चाहिए
मुझे डोंट वारी ब्रो
प्लीज अलसो इंटरेस्ट लर्निंग पाइथन प्लीज
मेक ए पोस्ट डोंट वारी
आपको पहले दिन से ही बताया है हमारे चैनल
पे हर एक चीज जो आप लोगों ने सोचा भी नहीं
होगा बट
उसके लिए सही टाइम पर सही टाइम पर आएगा
भारत चाहिए ना आप लोग सपोर्ट कीजिए हमारी
वीडियो कच्चे कैसे रिव्यू लाइक आप लोग
लाइक करना तो भूल ही गए हैं कमेंट तो रहते
ही नहीं है तो अब लोगों को कैसे पता चलेगा
हमारे बड़े में की हम लोग आप लोगों के लिए
बेस्ट चीज प्रोवाइड करते हैं
कैसे लोगों को कैसे पता चलेगा आप लोग
प्लीज एक बार हम सपोर्ट तो कीजिए
आप लोग हमें सपोर्ट कीजिए और हमें एक लेवल
तक लेकर जाइए
अभी पढ़ा सकते हैं जब हमें भी कुछ आप
लोगों से कुछ मिलन चाहिए हम आपसे क्या
मांगते हैं सब्सक्राइब मांगते हैं और व्यू
मांगते हैं लाइट मांगते और कमेंट मांगते
हैं इससे ज्यादा कुछ मांगा नहीं किसी से
₹1 तक
में से ही है सब नहीं कहो तो भाई बोल सकते
कोई सनी
बट फैमिली अगर मानते हो तो फैमिली की बात
करते तो फैमिली करना चाहिए
अगर आप लोग हमें सपोर्ट कीजिए
हम देख सकते हैं एक और इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
आपको सीखने वाला हूं की अगर आप अपनी मशीन
का रूल का पासवर्ड भूल जाते हैं तो कैसे
उसको रिकवर कर सकते
हो अगर रूट का पासवर्ड रिसेट करना सीखना
है अगर बोल देते तो आज भी बताया जाएगा इसी
क्लास में बताया जाएगा की कैसे अगर आप
अपनी मशीन ऑन करने बैठकर पासवर्ड भूल गए
तो कैसे अपलोड का पासवर्ड रिसेट कर सकते
हैं
अब
पुरी जम्मू कैसी गंद होती है
मतलब इसकी एक लिमिट होती है अभी तक मैं
जितनी भी फायर की है तो वह साड़ी के साड़ी
कमांड्स यहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेंगे
अभी तक
1672 कमांड्स मैंने फायर किया तो मेरी
हिस्ट्री
फाइल में जाके स्टोर हो गई है जितने भी
कमांड मैंने चलाई है पर एग्जांपल मैंने
क्या किया
आपको पता चल गया की साड़ी की साड़ी जो
कमांड है वह आपकी हिस्ट्री हिस्ट्री कमांड
में जाकर शेर हो जाति है एक आपकी
बैकग्राउंड में एक हिस्ट्री फाइल होती है
वहां पे जाके ये साड़ी की साड़ी से हो
जाति हैं चलो फिर देखो आपको हिस्ट्री
कमांड को ऑपरेट करना सीखना हूं पर
एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया है अभी आपको अगर
लास्ट हिस्ट्री आपको कमांड फायर नहीं करनी
आप क्या चाहते हो की मुझे अभी कमांड फायर
नहीं कर दी तो मैं क्या करना सिंपली जो
मैं लास्ट मोमेंट फायर की थी ना एक को आई
एम रिपीटिंग डी लास्ट कमांडो तो आपको क्या
करना है अरा सिंबल जो अरा सिंबल होता है
अब उसको क्या प्रेस कीजिए तो देखो अभी
उससे पहले मैं स्टिकमन फाएगी थी उससे पहले
एक को आम पे की थी उससे पहले हिस्ट्री फिर
उससे पहले एग्जिट उससे पहले टाइम उससे
पहले जो भी मैंने फायर किया था ये सारे
कमांड आपको देखने को मिल रही है तो सिंपली
क्या करना है आपको अरा डॉ अरा के साथ आपको
बढ़ाना है उसके बाद सिंपली हिट इंटर प्रेस
कर दिए तो कमांड आपकी एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगी
अगर आपको देखने को मिल रहा है तो एक और
तरीका होता है की अगर आपको अपनी प्रीवियस
कमांड को रिपीट करना है अगर आपको अपनी
प्रीवियस कमांड को रिपीट करना है उसके लिए
एक होता है डबल एस के लिए डबल एस की लेसन
मार्क सीट अब देखो ये आपको बता रहा है की
आपकी प्रवेश कुमार थे हिस्ट्री आप सिंपली
इंटर कर दीजिए इसमें बता दिया आपकी
प्रीवियस कमांड कौन सी थी हिस्ट्री थी पर
एग्जांपल अब मैं क्या करता हूं मैंने एक
टी ओ यू सी टच करता हूं मैं एक फाइल
77 मैंने क्रेडिट की उसके बाद
फिर मैंने क्या कर दिया एक बार एक बार कल
कमांड चला दी उसके बाद फिर मैंने क्या
किया
दें उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं रिमूव कर
दिया मैंने रिमूव और फाइल 77 को मैंने
क्या कर दिया रिमूव कर दिया इतने सारे
कमांड मैंने फायर कर दी और फिर से मैंने
क्या कर दिया अगर
आपको दिखा रहा है
तो अब देखो अब मैं इस फाइल को दोबारा
क्रिएट करना चाहता हूं कौन सी फाइल को
फाइल 77 को दोबारा क्रिएट करना था लेकिन
हम मैन्युअल कमांड को लिखना नहीं चाहते
लेकिन हम क्या करते हैं मैन्युअल कमांड को
लिखना नहीं चाहते तो उसके लिए क्या करेंगे
हम मैन्युअल कमांड पॉइंट लिखना चाहते तो
अब मैं ऐसा नहीं करना चाहता था टच फाइल 71
नहीं मैं क्या करूंगा तो मुझे एक क्या
करना है एस्केलेशन सिंबल मतलब रिलेशन
मार्क बैंक सेन सॉरी बैंक साइन जिसको हम
बोल सकते हैं इसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है
की कुछ स्ट्रिंग्स को एड करना होगा मतलब
एक प्रकार से सर्चिंग का कम कर रहा है ये
आपकी हिस्ट्री फाइल के अंदर तो आपको क्या
करना है इसके बाद कुछ स्ट्रिंग्स को एड
करना होगा उसे कमांड के पर एग्जांपल मुझे
कमांड का तो आइडिया है ना कौन सी कमांड है
टच है तो ओके टी ओ कर दिया उसके बाद
सिंपली टेंडर तेरे बता रहा हूं की आपकी जो
कमांड थी टच फाइल 77 ठीक है ये रहा तो
आपको लगा टच 57 है तो ये टेंडर कर दिया तो
फिर से क्या कर दिया वो वही कमांड है
एग्जीक्यूट हो गई तो अब मैं आपको एलएस
दिखाऊं अगर पैलेस फाइल 77 तो ये आपके
स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे रहा होगा सिंपली बता
रहा हूं देखो एक्सक्लेमेशन मार्क जो था ये
आपने उसे किया उसके बाद आपको क्या देना
पड़ेगा कुछ स्ट्रिंग को एड करना पड़ेगा
कौन सी स्ट्रिंग हनी चाहिए वो उसे कमांड
की स्ट्रिंग हनी चाहिए जो आप क्या करना
चाहते हो ढूंढ रहे हो एक प्रकार से
सर्चिंग का कम कर रहा है उसे कमांड के
अंदर प्रीवियस कमांड जो अभी तक आपने फायर
की है अगर वो कमांड आपने अभी तक फायर नहीं
की होगी अगर वो कमांड आप तक अपने नहीं
चलाई होगी तो उसके बड़े में आपको वो
इनफॉरमेशन नहीं मिलेगी और आपके ये स्क्रीन
पे देखा ही नहीं देगी तो बेसिकली क्या
करता है ये ये आपकी हिस्ट्री जो फाइल है
वहीं से कमांड को सर्च करता है अब मैं
क्या कहना चाहता हूं पर एग्जांपल मैं क्या
था अभी मैं हिस्ट्री आम चलाई मैंने इसने
पुरी की पुरी
100684 क्या कर दिया लाइंस को शो कर दिया
नहीं मैं लिमिट करना चाहता हूं ओनली मैं
10 कमांड का आउटपुट देखा था तो ये भी कर
सकता हूं हा आई एस टी और हिस्ट्री उसके
बाद क्या करना चाहता हूं आपको क्या लिखना
पड़ेगा 10 उंगली 10 लाइन के और तो हिट और
ओनली
ओके
एग्जांपल
हिस्ट्री
1 मिनट आईफोन हेल्प
ओके
और अगर आप ओनली हिस्ट्री 50 करते हैं तो
आपका करते हैं हिस्ट्री 50 कर दें
अब देखना ओनली वन से 100 तक की जितने भी
कमांड्स है देखो सीरियल नंबर वन से लेकर
अब वन तो है नहीं 7 10 नंबर तो ऐसे ही से
है तो साड़ी साड़ी 100 तक का स्क्रीन आप
स्क्रीन पर और कुछ शो कर दिया अगर आपने
हिस्ट्री किया हिस्ट्री ओनली अगर यहां पर
50 लिखा मैंने तो ये क्या का रहा है
फर्स्ट 50 कमांड को क्या का रहा है शो
करेगा इतनी है काउंटिंग में क्योंकि वन तू
थ्री फोर फाइव सिक्स सेवन है नहीं क्योंकि
वो स्टोर डिलीट हो राखी है
अगर आप क्या करना होगा अगर हमें अपने पुरी
हिस्ट्री को अरेंज करना है तो हम कैसे कर
सकते हैं
सी या क्लीन कर देगा हिस्ट्री हिफिन सी
सी अब ये कर दिया ओके व्हाट इसे डी
मां यार हिस्ट्री
ओके
[संगीत]
पता नहीं यार इस हिस्ट्री में के
1 मिनट
किसी भी मशीन के साथ मेरी इस दुनिया में
ओनली क्या है की हिस्ट्री कमांड क्लियर
ओके हिस्ट्री इन एक्शन ओके ओके
आईफोन 6 ऑप्शन कम ही नहीं कर रहा इसमें
क्या करोगे
लेटेस्ट जो काली मशीन ए रही है उनमें हो
सकता है की आईफोन सी ऑप्शन को क्या कर
दिया है हटा दिया गया होगा बट इन डी सेंस
की अगर मैं a1 किसी और दूसरी मशीन में
हिस्ट्री कमांड का फायर करता था वो कम कर
दिए तो अगर आपको क्या करना है की अगर आपको
अपनी पुरी की पुरी हिस्ट्री को अरेंज करना
है तो आप क्या कर सकते हो तो हिस्ट्री
हिफिन सी ऑप्शन उसे कर सकते हैं जो अभी
मैंने उसे किया जिसमें कम नहीं कम नहीं कर
रहे लेकिन किसी भी अदर मशीन में यूनिक्स
मशीन में कम करेगा अगर वो देखना चाहते हो
तो मैं अभी दूसरी मशीन ऑन करने में टेक
टाइम बट चलो अगर आप करके देखना उसके बाद
क्या की पर एग्जांपल मैंने आपको बोला ये
हिस्ट्री मेरी कमांड है हिस्ट्री उसके बाद
ये मेरी हिस्ट्री हिस्ट्री कमांड है तो
मुझे मैंने आपको ये बोला की मुझे ये वाली
जो ये
अकॉन्पिंग वाली जो हिस्ट्री वाली दिखाई दे
रहा है आपको ये वाली आपको फायर करनी है
डायरेक्टली अब क्या करोगे ओके सीधा आप
क्या कर डॉग डायरेक्टली तो अगर आप कुछ
डायरेक्टली फायर करना है तो सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है
उसके बाद इसका नंबर वन
अरे यार ओके 160 1674
रख देगा
तो इस तरीके से आप किसी भी उसको क्या कर
सकते हो हिस्ट्री वाले हिस्ट्री को क्या
कर सकते हो
एग्जीक्यूटिव पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या करना
है ये रहा क्लियर वाला ये 1634 को क्या
करना है एग्जीक्यूट करना है तो डायरेक्टली
कर सकता हूं 1 6 3 4 को कैसे बैंक साइन
ओके बैंक साइन बाय उसे करता हूं बैंक्स और
वन सिक्स थ्री फोर
कर देगा एक और तरीका होता है की जो आपकी
हिस्ट्री फाइल है उसमें सर्च करने का क्या
होता है सिंपली आपको क्या करना है ये आपको
कंट्रोल और आपने क्या कर दिया कंट्रोल आज
जैसे प्रेस किया कंट्रोल और पैसे के यहां
पे ए गया बी सी के आई सच मतलब क्या कर रहा
है अब आपको क्या करना है वो अल्फाबेट या
वो स्ट्रिंग प्रोवाइड करनी है पेट्रोल
कमांड की जिसको आप क्या करना चाहते हो
सर्च करना चाहते हो पर एग्जांपल
यू देखो आप जी चीज को टाइप करें
उसके बाद इंटर कर दीजिए ये क्या का रहा है
टच कर दिया एक फाइल क्रिएट कर दिया फाइल
77 के नाम से जो ऑलरेडी हमने क्रिएट किया
हुआ था इस तरीके से प्यार कर सकते हो आप
सच भी कर सकते हो अपनी हिस्ट्री फाइल के
अंदर कैसे सिंपली आपको करना है कंट्रोल आर
प्रेस करना है इस तरीके से चेंज हो जाएगा
यहां पर कोई भी स्ट्रिंग होती है शब्द का
नाम लेना है जो आप सब्सक्राइब
के अंदर
नेक्स्ट तो अब क्या करो आप हिस्ट्री कमांड
के बड़े में पढ़ रहे हो तो जब हिस्ट्री
कमांड के बड़े में पढ़ रहे हो आपको तीन
एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स के बड़े में पता
होना चाहिए मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट वैरियेबल्स
कौन-कौन से होते हैं जिनके बड़े में आपको
पर एग्जांपल सबसे पहले जो एनवायरनमेंट
वैरियेबल्स होता है आपका वो होता है
होल्ड्स डी नाम आईटी जो डी नाम और
लोकेशन ऑफ
योर बेस्ट हिस्ट्री बेस्ट
हिस्ट्री
फाइल हिस्ट्री
हा आई एस पी ओ आर ए हिस्ट्री फाइल डॉट आर
सी हिस्ट्री फाइल
साइज प्रोफाइल
आओ मैंने कमांड
यू कैन स्टोर इन इट्स कैट
नॉर्मल यूजर्स हो सभी में डिफाइंड रहते
हैं पर एग्जांपल मैं आपको दिखता हूं को
करके मैंने क्या कर रहा हूं अप को किया
मैंने और डॉलर और
इस साइज करता हूं मैं टेंडर
16 क्या कर सकते हो से कर सकते हैं
अपने जो आपके कैच है ना कच्चा की जो
कैपेसिटी है उसमें क्या-क्या है
उसके 1000 के बाद क्या होता है की वो
ओवरलैप करना शुरू कर देती है नेक्स्ट अगर
मैं आपको देखना आगे इसको आप क्या कर सकते
हो इसके साइज को बड़ा भी सकते हैं वो कैसे
बड़ा सकते हैं आप सिंपली क्या करो
इस साइज आप इस साइज कीजिए इक्वल कीजिए और
उसके बाद 5000 कर दीजिए पर एग्जांपल मैंने
₹5000
मैं एक और करके दिखता हूं तो इसकी फाइल
सजानेट होगी लेकिन ये एक टेंपरेरी है अगर
आपको परमानेंट करना है तो आपको डॉट बेस्ट
आरसी के अंदर जो डॉट बेस्ट आरसी वाले जो
फाइल्स है उसके अंदर जो इस साइज को जो
एनवायरनमेंट वेरिएबल है उसकी कैपेसिटी को
बढ़ाना होगा जो बाय डिफॉल्ट 1000 होती है
एवं से फेडरल लिस्ट मशीन के अंदर लेकिन
उसको क्या करना है आपको वहां पर जाकर
फाइल्स होती है जैसे
वाली यहां पर जो फाइल आपको देखने को मिल
रही है इसके अंदर आपको जाना है और क्या
करना है जो एनवायरनमेंट में वेरिएबल
मिलेगा इस साइज के नाम से उसके कैपेसिटी
आपको बड़ा देना है ये वाला वहां पर भी ऐसे
कर देना 5000 कर देना उसकी कैपेसिटी क्या
होता है परमानेंटली आपकी चेंज हो जाएगी तो
ये आपको पता चलेगा इस फाइल का मैंने बता
दिया अगर आप क्या करना चाहते हो इस साइड
का दिया और इस फाइल साइज
इस फाइल साइज
ओके तो एक चीज ध्यान में रखना की जितनी भी
आपकी जो हिस्ट्री होती है वो क्या होती है
की जो आपकी
मैंने अभी आपको फाइल दिखाई आपकी स्क्रीन
के सामने वो उधर उसके अंदर वो जो आज की जो
हिस्ट्री है वो तभी से होगी जब आपकी मशीन
क्या करेगी
जब हम लॉगिन करेंगे तभी वह हिस्ट्री आपकी
हिस्ट्री फाइल के अंदर जाकर से होगी
एडरवाइज किया की जो हिस्ट्री कमांड में
आपको देखने को मिल रही है वो कैसे मेमोरी
वाली हिस्ट्री आपको देखने को मिल रही है
अब आप क्या कर सकते हो अगर आप चाहे तो की
आप यह चाहता की मैं सिस्टम में कोई भी
कमेंट में फायर कर रहा हूं तो मैं
हिस्ट्री में से होने से रोकना चाहता हूं
की वो भी कर सकते हैं लेकिन आई कांत से की
गारंटी नहीं है की वो कम करें ना करें
लेकिन एक तरीका होता था आप स्पेस से
रिलेटेड करके मैंने जैसे डेट कमांड को
फायर किया हिट और अपना कम किया अगर मैं
हिस्ट्री कमांड चलता हूं क्या यह कम करेगा
या नहीं करेगा ओके ये कम कर गया मतलब क्या
है की अगर आप किसी कमांड फायर करने से
पहले अगर आप क्या कर देते हो स्पेस दे
देते हो तो क्या है उसके बाद कमांड का नाम
लिखना हूं मैंने एलिश किया हिफिन अल किया
तो ये आपका एक और ट्राई कर लेते हैं ल एस
आई एम किया उसके बाद मैं हिस्ट्री फाइल
चलता हूं की तंत्र तो ओके ये 1714 ही आपको
दिखाई दे रहा है इसके बाद ये अपडेट नहीं
हो रहा इसका मतलब क्या है की अगर आप किसी
कमांड से पहले स्पेस लगा डॉग तो उसका मतलब
ये है की आप वो उसे कमांड को आप हिस्ट्री
फाइल के अंदर से नहीं करना चाहते इसका
मतलब वो आपकी हिस्ट्री फाइल के अंदर नहीं
जाएगी
नेक्स्ट ये था आपका हिस्ट्री कमांड के
बड़े में
यह था आपका हिस्ट्री कमांड के बड़े में इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो आपकी
हिस्ट्री कमांड को आप मैनेज कर सकते हो
अगर आपने डिलीट करनी है एक और चीज शिखा
देता हूं अगर आपको हिस्ट्री डिलीट करनी है
तो भी देखते होंगे
और मैं क्या चाहता हूं ओनली 17 दिवाली है
17 फरवरी को डिलीट करना चाहता हूं वो व्यू
कर सकता हूं तो 17
ओके तो ये भी इसमें ऑप्शन हटा दिया बाकी
क्या की ये जो ऑप्शंस हैं सारे के सारे
किसी दूसरी यूनिट्स मशीन है उनमें कम करते
हैं एवं में अगर मैं फतोरा बेस के रेड
लाइट वाले या सैंटोस में उसे करूंगा तो
उनमें भी ये कम करते हैं बट काली के साथ
प्रॉब्लम हो गया हो सकता है काली में क्या
इसको मॉडिफाई किया गया है दिउ तू
सिक्योरिटी रीजंस हो सकता है
बट यहां पर कम नहीं कर रहे हैं
अब मैं आपको सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज आपको
सीखने जा रहा हूं की अगर आप क्या कर रहे
हो अगर आप अपनी मशीन का पर एग्जांपल
देता हूं
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है मैं शुरू डॉ कर
दिया
की आप बैठे अपनी मशीन को ऑन करने के लिए
उसे करने के लिए और आपने क्या किया आप
अपनी मशीन का पासवर्ड भूल गया पर एग्जांपल
मैं क्या कर रहा था मैंने जैसे ऑन किया तो
मैं अपनी मशीन का क्या कर जो इंटरफेस आता
है ना लोग इन वाला की वहां पर रूट पासवर्ड
है यूजर नाम पासवर्ड है वो मैं क्या भूल
गया एवं मी रूट का भी पासवर्ड भूल गया नो
आपको आता है अभी तक मैंने जो सिखाया है की
पांच विकेट कमांड से आप क्या कर सकते हो
की लॉगिन करने के बाद रूट यूजर से किसी का
भी पासवर्ड चेंज कर सकते हैं तो मैंने जब
पासवर्ड मैनेजमेंट का एक तो चैप्टर बताया
था आपको सिखाया थे 34 में किसी में से
करवाया था मैंने a3 फोन में तो 56 में
करवाया होगा तो आपको मैं बता चुका हूं अब
है की पर एग्जांपल अब आपको रूट का पासवर्ड
ही नहीं मालूम आपको रूट का पासवर्ड ही
नहीं मालूम और आप अपनी मशीन को लॉगिन
बाहर चले गए
और आपने क्या करना है आप मशीन को उसे करें
खासकर काली मिर्च के बड़े में बता रहा हूं
मैं आपको तो यह ओनली डेविन वाला सिस्टम
बता रहा हूं
किसी में ट्राई करने की कोशिश मत करना कम
करेगा लेकिन वहां पर कुछ पोस्ट है परफॉर्म
करने होते हैं अगर वो स्टेप अप परफॉर्म
नहीं करोगे तो आपको एरर मिलेगी और हो सकता
है आपकी मशीन भूत भी ना हो डोंट राइट ऑन
फेडरल बसेपे इसलिए रेड है ट्राई मत करना
क्योंकि उसमें कुछ और स्टेप परफॉर्म किया
जाते हैं उसके स्टेप्स अलग होते हैं रूट
पासवर्ड को रिसेट करने के तो ये स्पेशल
ओनली पर कॉलेज एक्स और पायलट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के लिए है दी दिन में खासकर
इन तीनों मशीन पे आप उसे कर सकते हो इसके
अलावा और मशीन पर ट्राई करने की कोशिश मत
करना क्योंकि वहां पर कुछ और स्टेप एडिशनल
करने पढ़ते हैं यह स्टेप परफॉर्म करने के
बाद करेगा ये कम लेकिन उसके बाद आपकी मशीन
भूत नहीं होगी क्योंकि वहां पर सिक्योरिटी
पॉलिसी अलग कम करती है फेडोरा बेस सिस्टम
के कैसे में तो अभी जो मैं स्टेप बता रहा
हूं बिल्कुल ध्यान से समझना तो अगर आप
क्या हुआ की आप किसी भी करण बस से आप अपनी
मशीन का रूट का पासवर्ड अगर आप भूल गए और
आप क्या कहना चाहते हैं आपने मशीन को रे
रिबूट करना रिसेट करना चाहते हो उसका रूट
का पासवर्ड तो वो कैसे कर सकते हो सिंपली
आपने क्या किया पावर ऑन किया ताकि मशीन
स्टार्ट होगी अब क्या हुआ की आपको क्या
करना है जैसे ये ऑप्शन ए जाता है इसके बाद
जैसे ही आता है तो आपको सिंपली यहां पर
प्रेस करना ए जैसे ही आप प्रेस करोगे आई
तो आपको यहां पर क्या है बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस
देखने को मिलेंगे सिस्टम सेट पैरामीटर ये
देखने का कोई मिल रहा है 1 मिनट आपको मैं
जूम करके दिखा देता हूं अगर दिखे रहा होगा
तो
यहां आपको प्रेस आई करने के बाद जूम कर
देता हूं अगर आपको नहीं दिखे रहा होगा एक
मिनट
1 मिनट 1 मिनट
अभी आपको दिखाई दे रहा हूं अच्छे से तो
आपको क्या करना है की सिंपली अभी ये
स्क्रीन आपके सामने ए जाएगी तो आपको क्या
करना है यहां पे एक लाइनेक्स वाली लाइन
आएगी लास्ट में जो जो नीचे नीचे देखो ये
रहा ये लाइनेक्स वाली ये लाइन दिखाई दे
रहे हो
जिसमें मेरा अभी ये कस्टमर मूव कर रहा है
देखो ये रहा क्या अगर मैं आपको हाईलाइट
करके दिखाऊं ये रहा ये रहा एक मिनट ये रहा
मैं जहां पर मेरा ये सब था ना ये रहा आप
ये हाथ का सिंबल बना हुआ है ये रैली
नेक्स्ट वाली इस लाइन पे जाना है आपको
यहां पर जाना है अपने कर्सर को लेकर जाना
है तो सिंपली क्या करना है आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन पे यहां पे लेक जो और सबसे
लास्ट में जो लास्ट में ए एचडी 64 जाके
जाके ऐसे जाओगे सबसे लास्ट में ये कौन सा
है आपको दिखाई दे रहा हूं ना नो किट्स
प्लस
तो आपको क्या करना है
तो आपको इसको क्या करना है डिलीट करना
डिलीट कर दो
क्या कर दो रु का मतलब ओनली आपको क्या
करना रु मतलब क्या है ना रीड राइट उसके
बाद स्पेस देना है इन आईटी करना है उसके
बाद इक्वल साइन उसके बाद स्लैश बिन स्लैश
स्लैश मेंस ली बेस्ट करना है आपको / बेस्ट
करना है यहां तक फिर से बता देता हूं आप
लाइनेक्स वाले उसपे क्या करोगे लाइन पे
आओगे सबसे लास्ट में जाओगे वहां पे आपको
देखने को चीज तीन चीज मिलेगी सबसे लास्ट
में आर ओ रीड ओनली क्यूट और आपको देखना है
देखने को मिलेगा उन तीनों डिलीट कर देना
है आपको उसके बाद क्या लेंगे आरो की जगह
आर डब्लू स्पेस यूनिट इक्वल तू स्लैश मिंस
बेस्ट और सिंपली आप इसके बाद क्या कर देना
कंट्रोल एक्स जैसे आप कंट्रोल एक्स करोगे
आपकी मशीन भूत करना स्टार्ट कर देगी जैसे
ही आप क्या करोगे कंट्रोल एक्स करोगे तो
आपके मशीन क्या करेगी भूत करना स्टार्ट कर
देगी
डिपेंड करता है
टाइम भी ले सकता है
ओके तो अब आपके स्क्रीन पर कुछ इस तरीके
से ए जाएगा आपके स्क्रीन पर कुछ इस तरीके
से ए जाएगा देखने को रूल
आपका फॉरवर्ड स्लैश अब क्या की रूट
पार्टीशन के अंदर आप कहां पर आप रूट
पार्टीशन के अंदर है ना की ये रूट के
फॉर्म अकाउंट में अब आपको यहां पे एक चीज
कंफर्म करनी है एम ओ यू एन टी माउंट
सिंपली हिटलर जैसे आप इंटर करोगे तो आपको
सबसे लास्ट में चेक करना है मैं आपको फिर
से एक करके दिखता दे रहा सबसे लास्ट में
आपको ये चेक करना 0.5 करने के बाद की
स्लैशदेव सदा वन ऑन ये रहा ये फारवर्ड है
आपको दिखे रहा है फॉरवर्ड स्लाइस आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है की
तो ये जो फॉरवर्ड है इसको बोल सकते हैं
आगे फॉरवर्ड स्लाइस आपको जो देखने को मिल
रहा है यहां पर तो ये जो रूट पार्टीशन
वाला जो आपको देखने में मिलता है क्या ये
माउंट है
आपको रियल टाइम से पहले आपको देखना या आर
ओ नहीं होना चाहिए यहां क्या नहीं होना
चाहिए और रीड ओनली नहीं होना चाहिए यहां
क्या होना चाहिए
फ्री ड्राइव
करना है अगर आपको यहां पर आर ओ मिल गया तो
सिंपली आपको क्या करना है हम आपको कमांड
लिख के दिखता हूं माउंट उसके बाद री माउंट
करना है उसके बाद उसके बाद आर डब्लू लिखना
है आपको माउंट री माउंट करना रु कर देना
है ये कमांड आपको फायर करनी है अगर यहां
पर आरो देखने को मिलता है लेकिन अभी हमें
करने की जरूर नहीं है अब इसके बाद आप क्या
कर सकते हो पासवर्ड चेंज करने के लिए जो
हम कमांड उसे करते थे सिंपली रूट का
पासवर्ड
करना चाहते हो
हम आपको नहीं बताने वाला गेम
इंटर पासवर्ड अपडेट सक्सेस प्लीज इसका
मतलब मेरा क्या हुआ पासवर्ड चेंज हो गया
रिसेट हो गया अब मुझे सिंपली क्या करना है
रिबूट करना है इस मशीन को सिंपली क्या
करना है
रिबूट करना तो मैं क्या करूंगा
एस बिन उसके बाद यूनिट आई एन आई टी ये कर
दो और सिंपली देख लीजिए ध्यान से
एग्जीक्यूट करो इन आईटी का क्या करना ये
भी एक लिमिट करने की अब मैं क्या जो
बाइनरी फाइल है रिबूट करने की मशीन को वो
मैं एग्जीक्यूट करवा रहा हूं एडरवाइज
रिबूट भी लिखोगे तो कर जाएगा कम नहीं तो
ये क्या है की आप ऐसे करो एग्जीक्यूट
स्लैश मीन इन आईटी
अभी आपकी मशीन रिबूट होना स्टार्ट हो
जाएगी नए वाले ग्रेजुएशन के साथ जो आपने
रिसेट किया हैं और आप सक्सेसफुली क्या कर
सकते हो आप सक्सेसफुली आप अपनी मशीन को
क्या कर सकते हो देखो अब मैंने रूट लिखा
मैंने और उसके बाद दाल देता हूं जो भी
मैंने अभी रिसेट किया था
मैं क्या कर गया
पासवर्ड को कैसे रिसेट किया जाता है खुद
की मशीन
बताइए सभी
बताइए बताइए बताइए
क्या सब को चाट में यस या नो सबको पासवर्ड
रिसेट करना ए गया या नहीं आया
तो एक दो और कमांड है जो मैंने आपको बताने
बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है मेरे लिए तो वह
कौन-कौन सी कमांड है उसके बाद हम डाउट
सेशन लेंगे आपका अभी वह कौन सी कमांड है 1
मिनट का मुझे टाइम दीजिए ओके ओके
जूम कर देता हूं एक तो होती है
सोर्स
अल्फाबेटिकल
शॉर्ट करती है
पर एग्जांपल
कर दिया इसके अंदर बहुत साड़ी फायदे देखो
ये वैसे भी सॉर्टेड है तो मैं कम करता हूं
इनको मानसून्टेड कर देता हूं पर एग्जांपल
मैं क्या करता हूं इसके अंदर
और इसके लिए मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
96 डायरेक्टली ओके
उसका उत्तर
ओके
और शॉर्ट करूंगा सिंपली टेंडर
देता हूं पंप मैंने इसमें कुछ रिपीट कर
दिया है मैंने क्या कर दिए मैंने क्या
किया कुछ इसमें रिपीट कर देता हूं पर
एग्जांपल मैंने यहां पर फिर से ऐसे कन
सचिन कर दिया नेक्स्ट मैंने क्या कर दिया
नितेश और इट्स नितेश और फिर से मैंने ये
लिखा है इसमें अनिल ए एन आई ल अनिल लिख
दिया और मैं इसको फिर से से कर देता हूं
अब मैं क्या करता हूं ओके मैं शॉर्ट कर
दूंगा इस फाइल को मैंने शॉर्ट कर दिया
शॉर्टकट का बेसिकली करना है अल्फाबेटिकल
फाइल्स के कीबोर्ड को जो व्हाट्सएप को
सॉर्ट कर देती है अगर उसमें प्रॉब्लम्स
हैं तो कॉलम्स के अकॉर्डिंग भी कर सकते हो
कैसे पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया अगर मैं
शॉर्ट करना चाहता हूं उसके बाद क्या करना
चाहता हूं मैं शॉर्ट के बाद क्या चाहता
हूं की मैं ओनली अकॉर्डिंग तू फर्स्ट कलम
मैं क्या कहना करता हूं अपने फाइल को
सॉर्टेड कर दो
अकॉर्डिंग तू फर्स्ट कलम ये क्या करेगा
शॉर्टकट है उसके बाद फाइल नाम डॉट टी एक्स
टी कर देगा नेक्स्ट अगर मैं का रहा हूं
ओन्ली अकॉर्डिंग तू कलम तू क्या अकॉर्डिंग
करना चाहता हूं तो ये हो गया अकॉर्डिंग
शॉर्ट कर देगा
कलम के अकॉर्डिंग इसका शॉर्ट करना चाहता
हूं अल्फाबेटिकल तो वो भी मैं कर सकता हूं
इस तरीके से भी आप कर सकते हैं शॉर्ट
कमांड में उसे कर सकते हैं अब एक कमांड और
होती है जिसका नाम है यूनिक एक कमांड और
होती है यूनिक यू एन आई के यूनिक का मतलब
क्या है की डुप्लीकेट डुप्लीकेट जो शब्द
हैं उनको क्या कर देना डिलीट कर देना
डुप्लीकेट शब्द को क्या कर देना डिलीट कर
देना
और एक चीज ध्यान रखना यूनिक कमांड को आप
सभी उसे कर सकते हैं
मतलब आपको क्या करना है किया तो पहले
शॉर्ट कमांड का उसे करके आप अपनी फाइल को
सॉर्ट कर लीजिए उसके बाद यूनिक कमांड
चलाइए तो डुप्लीकेशन
कम करेगा और अगर आपको लगता है की नहीं मैं
भाई इतनी मेहनत नहीं करता सिंपली क्या कम
कीजिए आप क्या मैंने क्या किया कैट किया
मैंने tmp.t उसके बाद सिम फाइव सिंपल किया
उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया शॉर्ट कर दिया
इसको पहले शॉर्ट करने के बाद उसको बस
मैंने क्या कर दिया उसको आउटपुट इसमें दे
दिया यूनिक यू और आई के यूनिक कर दिया ये
इसने क्या कर दिया जो डुप्लीकेट थे उनको
क्या कर दिया रिमूव कर दिया आपकी स्क्रीन
के सामने और आपका आउटपुट शो कर दिया अगर
मैं क्योंकि ये क्या स्क्रीन में कम कर
रहा है इसमें आप क्या है उसके बाद आपको से
करना पड़ेगा ऑन स्क्रीन कम कर रहा है तो
इस तरीके से ये कम करता है शॉर्ट कमांड और
यूनिक कमांड तो यह हमारी कुछ कमांड थी
जिनके बड़े में आपको पता होना चाहिए
क्योंकि जब भी कर रहे होंगे तो आपको सबसे
ज्यादा जरूर पड़ती है सोर्टिंग की और
यूनिक यूनिक
कमांड्स भी आपको पता होना चाहिए तो यह था
आज का सेशन और उसके बाद हम
सेशन को और अभी नहीं करेंगे आपका 15 मिनट
का डाउट सेशन है अभी तक जितने भी मैंने 13
तक जो भी कुछ आपको करवाया है वो उससे
रिलेटेड आप कुछ भी पूछ सकते हैं
तो 5 मिनट का समय निकालिए और आप लोग हमारे
पेज पर जाइए जो हमारा ऑफिशल लिंकडइन पेज
वहां पर जाइए यहां पर इसलिए वीडियो इसका
लिंक मिलेगा वहां पर लाइक और कमेंट कीजिए
ताकि लोगों को पता चले की आप लोगों ने आज
के राशिफल है तो उसमें सिर्फ टॉपिक का नाम
मेंशन कर दिए इससे ज्यादा हमें कुछ भी
नहीं चाहिए ओनली टॉपिक के नाम आप लोग वहां
पे कर दीजिए मेंशन उसके अलावा कुछ भी नहीं
चाहिए क्योंकि उसे क्या दूसरे लोगों को
मिलता है उन लोगों से भी रिक्वेस्ट है जो
बाद में सेशन को रिकॉर्डिंग सेशन को देखते
हैं जो रिकॉर्डिंग देखना पसंद करते हैं
लाइव सेशन में आना पसंद नहीं है प्लीज वो
भी 1 मिनट का समय निकालिए और इतना कम कर
सकते हैं हमारे लिए अगर आपके पास लिख
देंगे प्रोफाइल नहीं है बना लीजिए अगर
क्यों बना लीजिए उसको बेनिफिट बताता हूं
आपको अगर आप लिख देंगे प्रोफाइल बनोगे तो
क्या होता की इस लिंकडइन ही एक ऐसी चीज है
जहां पर आपके यहां जो प्रोफाइल मॉनिटर की
जाति है किसी भी कंपनी में आप कम करने के
लिए जाओगे तो आपको क्या करना है तो आपके
कंपनी क्या करती है सबसे पहले एक ये भी
चेक करते हैं क्या लिख दें इसकी प्रोफाइल
है या नहीं है इंडियन में प्रोफाइल होने
से फायदा है की जो भी आप स्किल जेन कर रहे
हैं कोई भी सर्टिफिकेट कर रहे हो किसी भी
चीज का तो आप सर्टिफिकेशन करने के तुरंत
बाद उसको क्या है लेकिन प्रोफाइल को अपने
एक रिज्यूम की तरह उसे कीजिए उसमें अपनी
क्वालिफिकेशन एड कर दीजिए क्योंकि जो आप
लिख देंगे
सर्च करते हो क्योंकि इंडियन पे ही साड़ी
कंपनी ऑपरेट कर दिए हैं वहीं से क्या है
आप जो क्लियर सर्च करते हैं और वहीं से
आपके लिए भी रिक्वेस्ट ए शक्ति है तो
प्लीज वहीं से आपको ऐसे जुम्मे उसे की है
लिंक देने पे कोई प्रोजेक्ट कलर तो
लिंकडइन पर दाल लीजिए आपने कोई ग्रेजुएशन
कर लिया ठीक है उसको ग्रेजुएशन कलम को आप
अपने क्वालिफिकेशन एड कर दीजिए
कोई भी आपके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन कहां से
लेने या तो आपकी सोशल मीडिया से लगा या
फिर रिज्यूम चलेगा तो उसको भी उसे कीजिए
आपके लिए भी बहुत बेनिफिट होगा लेकिन
प्रोफाइल को क्रिएट करना इन फ्यूचर
क्योंकि आज नहीं तो कल इंडियन प्रोफाइल की
जरूर होने वाली है बैटरी है की उसको उसे
करके पुरानी बना लीजिए अच्छी चीजों के लिए
उसे कीजिए
ओके
बात करते हैं
स्टार्टिंग से
[संगीत]
राधे राधे
अंधा का जय श्री राम जय श्री राम भाई जय
श्री राम
ओके आप लोग बेस में इंटरेस्ट हो तो यह
मुझे बताइए अगर मैं भैंस का कोर्स आप
लोगों के लिए डिजाइन भी करूंगा
बताओ चाट में बताइए
प्रॉमिस करते हैं तो मैं उसके लिए आपके
लिए सोच सकता हूं अभी फ्री में डिलीवर कर
दूंगा
फ्री में डिलीवर कर दूंगा अगर मुझे अच्छे
खेस आप सब्सक्राइब दिवा दिए और लाइक मिलता
दीजिए
तो मैं व्यू और
ऑटोमेटेकली बेस्ट कंटेंट है
किसी भी सर्टिफिकेट इंजीनियर
यह घर पर बैठकर आप विंडो की जगह लाइनेक्स
पर खाना पसंद करना चाहते हो लेकिन इसको
उसे करना चाहते हो डेली बेसिस पे तो इस
कोर्स के बेस पर डेली बेसिस पे अपने
लाइनेक्स मशीन को उसे कर सकते हैं
यस यस में क्या डाउट होता है प्लीज
एक्सप्लेन
करने के लिए मुझे लगता की आज आप पहले बार
जॉइन कीजिए की है तो इसलिए मैं आप लोगों
को रिटर्न आपको रिकमेंड करूंगा की आप लोग
जैसे यह और हो जाता है लाइव सेशन के
साथ-साथ आप एक कम करो स्टार्टिंग से हमारी
वीडियो देखना स्टार्ट करो आपको एच और एवरी
स्टेप डिटेल में मिलेगा हर एक कमांड
गलत हो गया स्क्रीनशॉट
अरे वो कम करेगा
कम करेगा
ओके तो तेल मी वंस ओके पाइप
जोड़ने का कम करता है मतलब पाइप सिंबल
क्या करता है की जो पहले वाली जो कमांड
होती है उसका जो आउटपुट है वो दूसरी जो
कमांड होगी पाइप सिंबल के बाद में उसका
इनपुट बना देगा मतलब जोड़ना पाइपिंग करना
वही है इसका मतलब जो पहले जो कमांड थी
दे नहीं सकते क्योंकि फाइल का नाम थी उसका
जो फाइनली लिखी हुई है तो सिंपली मैंने
पाइप सिंबल लगा दिया बोला एक कम करो कैट
टीएनपी जो टेक्स्ट फाइल है उसका जो आउटपुट
ए रहा है उसको आप क्या करोगे शॉर्ट कमांड
के इनपुट में दाल दीजिए तो ओके इसने क्या
कर दिया फिर अब इसने क्या कर दिया जो
इनपुट आउटपुट नहीं डायरेक्शन आप लोगों ने
पढ़ा होगा जहां पर दो क्लासेस में इसको
डिस्कस किया गया है अगर ब्रो अगर आपने
डिस्कस किया अगर आपने नहीं पढ़ा है इनपुट
आउटपुट डायरेक्शन डेट थ्री और a4 दोनों को
एक बार रिवाइज कीजिए आपको ये क्लियर हो
जाएगा अभी मैं बता देता हूं तो इसका जो
आउटपुट आया है इसने इसका क्या बना दिया
इसके लिए इनपुट का कम किया क्योंकि फाइव
सिमिलर इसको जोड़ दिया क्योंकि शॉर्ट
कमांड को कम करने के लिए एक फाइल का नाम
चाहिए था अभी यहां पर मैंने क्या है कुछ
भी नहीं दिया ये कहां से लेना इनपुट ये
इधर से इनपुट ले रहा है उसपे कम कर रहा है
उसके बाद फिर से मैंने पाइप लगा दिया सो
डायरेक्ट की जो ये आउटपुट आया था आपकी
स्क्रीन के सामने अब ये देखिए ये जो
आउटपुट आया था इसके सामने अब मैंने इसका
भी जो आउटपुट है इसको इनपुट बना दिया
तो मुझे ये बता दीजिए की आपको समझ में आया
नहीं आया तो
क्लियर हो गया होगा
थैंक यू ब्रो आप लोगों का इसमें
उसके लिए रहे दिल से धन्यवाद
लाइव पर डी फर्स्ट टाइम
कीजिए अभी भी आपके पास टाइम है युटुब पे
अवेलेबल रहेगी तो जल्दी से कम कीजिए अगर
आपको सीखना तो अब डेली एक वीडियो देखिए
अगर आपके पास ज्यादा टाइम तो दो देखिए
उसको कर कीजिए तो यू बिल बी सिक्योरिटी
और कुछ बताइए और किस कोई डाउट अभी तक किसी
और कुछ पूछना है
बताइए
[संगीत]
टीम एडिटर
समझ में नहीं आया तो बताओ
टुमारो
मैक्सिमम लोग आई अटेंड कीजिए इंजॉय कीजिए
बाकी
परसेंटेज
को पहले बार कोई आपको मुझे लगता है
इंटेलिजेंस के ऊपर
मुझे नहीं लगता
2 घंटे 3 घंटे का है
10 घंटे का आराम से 10 से 12 घंटे का आराम
से है
तो मुझे बताइए
इट्स ओके ओके
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग का ही पार्ट है
का मतलब ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस होता है
जिसका मतलब क्या होता है
वह क्या कम वही तो कम आप इनफॉरमेशन
गैलरी
टेस्ट रख सकते हैं
तो
चाचा
नहीं है
तो कल शाम के सिक्स ओ क्लॉक
स्टार्ट होने जा रहा है तो सभी आई अटेंड
कीजिए और साथ में और बाकी लोगों को लेकर
जाइए इसमें कोई कंडीशन नहीं की इसमें
टेक्निकल नॉन टेक्निकल आईटी नाउन आईटी कोई
भी ए सकता है क्योंकि ये जनरल नॉलेज है एक
जनरल परपज कोर्स है इसे कोई भी सिख सकता
है एवं मैं बोलना हूं की हर एक इंसान को
ओपन 100 से इंटेलिजेंस करना आना चाहिए
क्योंकि कभी किसी भी मुसीबत में फसता है
तो वो सो दादा की कभी निकाल सके ऐसी कभी
सिचुएशन से बाकी ज्यादा नहीं पसंद लेकिन
एक लेवल तक अपने बड़े में विशेष कर सकता
है
ओके बाय बाय गुड नाइट सेशन